[موسيقى]
يقولون ان الفلسفه واحيانا الفيزياء تحاول
اقناع الناس بان رجلا ابكم قال لرجل اصم
ان رجلا اعمى شاهد رجلا اكسح يلحق برجل
اكثر ليمنعه من جز شعر رجل اصلع لكن
الحقيقه هي ان الفلسفه لا تفعل ذلك ولا
الفيزياء بل ان بعض المنافقين يحاولون ان
يقنع الناس بان سفله القوم هم اشرافهم وان
اللصوص يؤتمنون على الاوطان الى العناوين
[موسيقى]
هل يتسول ماكرون امن اوروبا الغربيه عند
سور الصين العظيم
زعيم ديني هندوسي يدعو الى احتلال مكه
والقضاء على الاسلام
محاوله اغتيال امام مسجد في نيوجيرسي على
يد تركي كردي
عاصفه قضائيه تهز رجال الكنيسه
الكاثوليكيه المتحرشين في امريكا
الدلايله ما يتحرش بطفل امام اهله
والكاميرات ثم يعتذر
المذهب المغامسي الجديد وهيئه كبار
العلماء في السعوديه ترد
قاض مغربي تاخذه الرافه بثلاثه شبان
اغتصبوا طفله حملت منهم
[موسيقى]
مرحبا وسبحان الله سبحان الله الذي جعل
الرئيس الفرنسيين ايمانويل ماكرون يعيش
ازمه في كل مكان في العالم منذ ان ادعى ان
الاسلام يعيش ازمه في كل مكان بالعالم
يقول شاب مسلم مسالم يكره الجدل والدجل
والرجل ضرب اللسان
مع تسارع عجله التسويه في اليمن على ايقاع
عربه المصالحه السعوديه الايرانيه التي
صنعت في الصين ومع تراجع شعبيه ماكرون
داخل فرنسا الى الحضيض وقبل ان يستقبل
طلابه هولندا زائرهم ايمانيول مكروم
بالاهانات والتعنيف اللفظي بسبب قمعه
المتظاهرين السلميين في المدن الفرنسيه
بقوه العسكر والسلاح
وتجرئه على قيم الحريه والديمقراطيه
الاوروبيه طلب عندليب الاليزيه بهدله في
اقاصي الارض قيل فزحف شرقا متسولا ومتوسلا
امنا اوروبا الغربيه عند سور الصين العظيم
يقولون
لكنه عاد الى باريس ببضاعه كلام صيني من
النوع الاستهلاكي الذي لا يطفئ حربا قد
تهدد اوروبا بالظلم والظلام شعبيه
ايمانويل تراجعت في فرنسا الى ادنى مستوى
لها خلال زيارته الى مدينه كانتون بجنوب
الصين اختلم ماكرون فرصه امام الاف الطلاب
للتنديد بالحرب الروسيه بعد فشله في اقناع
الرئيس الصيني بلعب دور الوساطه لكن
الرئيس الصيني اكتفى خلال حديثه مع ماكرون
بالاشاره الى تقديم دعم الاستئناف
المحادثات اينما ذهب يتعرض للاهانه بهذه
الكلمات سخر متابعون من تعمد رئيس الصين
وضع ضيفه الفرنسي على طاوله تشبه الحديقه
ذكرت بطاوله بوتين المركب فهل تملك الدول
العظمى معطيات لا نعرفها تمنع جلوس
الزعماء قرب ماكرون على طاوله
ماكرون يرتكب خطا بروتوكوليا فادحا في
حضره زعيم الصين فيضع يده في جيبه وهو
واقف بجواره مدير البروتوكول الصيني مش
اكثر طلب منه سحب يديه فورا واعتدال وقفته
فاعتدل على الفور في الخلاصه ماكرون اذل
نفسه والاتحاد الاوروبي في الصين تقول
صحيفه تيليجراف البريطانيه وقد اظهر مدى
بطاحه امام زعيمها القوي سجن بينج ماكرون
لم يعد من الصين خالي الوفاظ تماما بل
تمتع بالاستمتاع الى معزوفه صينيه قديمه
صب عليها التلفزيون الصيني الرسمي اهتماما
غير عدي من كل زياره ماكرون فقد دعا
الرئيس الصين سجن بينج ضيفه الفرنسي الى
عرض موسيقي وشرح له معنى المعزوفه
التراثيه واغنيتها تحت عنوان الجبال
العاليه والمياه المتدفقه
فتدفقت دماء الخيبه الى دماغ ماكرون
ودائما بحسب المراقبين
الاداره الروسيه ردت على ماكرون الرافض
لنشر الدول العظمى اسلحه نوويه
فسالته متحدثه وزاره الخارجيه ماريا سليطه
اللسان هل يقصد ماكرون ما تفعله الولايات
المتحده في اوروبا ماذا سيحدث في حال
اتحدث روسيا والعالم الاسلامي سؤال وجهه
السياسي الروسي فلاديمير جيري نوفسكي قبل
وفاته يستعيده الاعلام الروسي في ذكرى
رحيله الاولى
جوابا على سؤال
قام معارض سوري بعمليه حسابيه بسيطه فوجد
انه عندما اتحدت روسيا مع سوريا كانت
النتيجه حوالي مليون قتيل ومفقود واكثر من
عشره ملايين مهجر ونازح وسجين ومعاق وجريح
وعشرت ملايين فقير معدم داخل البلاد طبعا
لا تتحمل روسيا وحدها المسؤوليه لكن
الاطراف الاخرى لن تغيب ايضا لذلك اذا
اتحد العالم الاسلامي مع روسيا سيحظى
بفرصه موت خمسه بالمئه من سكانه وتهجير
خمسين بالمئه من مواطنيه ووضع الباقين على
حديده الفقر فلا تفوت الفرصه ايها
المسلمون ينصحكم المعارض السوري
شامل الهوى
بعيون مظلوم
مناضل واذوب في ساحاتها
بين المساجد
والمنازل
حذفت الحكومه الهنديه تاريخ المسلمين من
المنهاج التعليمي للطلاب
فطمصت الفصل الذي يروي فتره الحكام المغول
المسلمين كما تم حذف مذابح معاصره لجماعات
التطرف المنسوبه الى الدين الهندوسي بحق
المسلمين تقول صحيفه الجارديان ان رئيس
الحكومه الحاليه نارين رمودي متورط فيها
في ظل هذه الاجواء الحكوميه الاقصائيه
للمسلمين وجد ايقونه الارهاب في الهند
الزعيم الهندوسي المتطرف جدا
يتسار رسواتي وجد اللحظه الذهبيه للاعلان
عن مشروعه الحلم باحتلال مكه المكرمه وغزو
الكعبه المشرفه واستعاده بئر زمزم فهو نهر
هندوسي في اد
وذلك للقضاء على الاسلام وفق تعبيره
الاكثر غرابه ووحشيه قوله ان الهندوس
قادرون الان على احتلال مكه لكنه لم يقل
كيف ومن اي جهه سيهاجمونها وباي قوه بشريه
وعسكريه هذا صار سواتي اما نارين درامودي
رئيس الحكومه الهنديه التي توفر البيئه
المناسبه لهذه الوحوش فما تزال اوسمه
خليجيه
ذهبيه تزين صدره الحاقد يقولون
ويتمتع بعلاقات طيبه مع مختلف دول الاقليم
العربيه وغير العربيه وقال اليوم هو الوقت
المناسب لتوحيد العالم ضد الاسلام والجهاد
الاسلامي وعلينا كجماعه الهندوسيه ان نغز
مكه المكرمه ونستولي على الكعبه المشرفه
[موسيقى]
ما يزال المسلمون في ولايه نيوجيرسي
الامريكيه ينتظرون نتائج تحقيقات الشرطه
مع شريف زوربا التركيه الذي اقدم على عمل
لا يمت الى اسمه شريف بصله زوربه حاول
اغتيال امام مسجد عمر بن الخطاب رضي الله
عنه في نيوجيرسي الشيخ الامريكي من اصل
مصري سيد النقيب اثناء امامته صلاه الفجر
بالمصلين ووجهت الشرطه اليه تهمه القتل
العمد من الدرجه الاولى
شقيق الشيخ سيد وهو الشيخ عبد الخالق
النقيب كان بين المصلين ونفى في حديث معنا
ان يكون ما حدث عملا ارهابيا لو كان عمل
ارهابي كان قتل المصلين اللي حواليه وهرب
تبين بعد ذلك انه يحمل الجنسيه
وهو كردي من الاتراك وهذا الرجل كان يتردد
بعض الاوقات الى المسجد لا يتحدث اللغه
العربيه ولا يتحدث الانجليزيه اليس بيننا
وبينه اي علاقه لا من قريب ولا من بعيد
ولم نعرف ما الدافع لهذه الجريمه النكرات
عاصفه جديده في وجه رجال الدين الامريكيين
المتهمين باغتصاب الاطفال اثارها المدعي
العام في ولايه مريلاند بنشره تقريرا عن
تعذيب واغتصاب لاكثر من 600 طفل على مدى
عقود في واحده من الكنائس الكاثوليكيه بعد
خمس سنوات من التحقيق الذي تضمن شهادات من
الضحايا واعترافات من القصاوسه ومساعديهم
والمدرسين
بجرائمهم احد الشمامسه اعترف باغتصاب اكثر
من مئه طفل
تسترت الكنيسه طويلا على الاعتداءات بحسب
المدعي العام لميريلاند الذي دعا ضحايا
اعتداءات الكنائس الاخرى الى التقدم
بالشكاوى القانونيه
كانوا يرتكبون فعلتهم خلف الابواب
الدلايل لاما فعل شيئا منها امام
الكاميرات والجمهور بحسب معلقين
[موسيقى]
لاحقا قدم مكتب الدلائل مع اعتذاره عن
تصرفاته الشاذه لكنه قال انها كانت بدافع
بريء صحيح ان اخراج اللسان يعتبر احيانا
طريقه للتحيه في التباد لكن اخراجه فقط
وليس كما فعل العجوز حادثه التحرش اللايف
ذكرت بتحقيقات استقصائيه اوروبيه العام
الماضي تحت عنوان
البوذيه وقانون الصمت كشفت عن انتهاكات
جنسيه اقدم عليها زعماء روحيون في الطائفه
البوذيه تجاه الاطفال والنساء فضلا عن
اختلاس الاموال اشاره الى ان الدلاله
الرابع عشر يعيش في الهند منذ انتفاضته
الفاشله التي قاد اقليم التيبت فيها عام
1959 على سلطات الصين فنفي ولجا الى الهند
لكنه نصح اوروبا مؤخرا بترحير اللاجئين عن
اراضيها وحذرها من الاسلام والمسلمين عدد
محدود يمكنهم البقاء لكن ان تصبح في
النهايه اوروبا بلدا مسلما هذا مستحيل او
بلدا افريقيا هذا مستحيل ايضا
نشات المذاهب الفقهيه الاربعه عند
المسلمين من اهل السنه والجماعه في احضان
فقه الصحابه رضي الله عنهم ثم انتظم علماء
التابعين بمنهجهم وكان ائمه المذاهب
الفقهيه الاربعه المتبوعه اليوم الى ان
ظهر من كم يوم رجل يقال له صالح المغامسي
غمس غموسا في المذاهب الاربعه واعلن عن
رجائه باي ينشئ مذهبا خامسا هو المذهب
المغامسي الجديد ما استدعى ردا عاما من
الامانه العامه لهيئه كبار العلماء في
السعوديه الرجاء الذي انا ارجوه من الله
عز وجل ان يحققه
وليعذرني اخوتي العلماء
ان ينشا الله على يدي مذهبا اسلاميا فقهيا
جديدا اوضحت الامانه العمل لهيئه كبار
العلماء في السعوديه ان الدعوه الى انشاء
مذهب فقهي اسلامي جديد تفتقد الموضوعيه
والواقعيه وبينتنا الفقه الاسلاميه
بمذاهبه الفقهيه المعتبره واجتهاداته
المتنوعه يستجيب لجميع مطالب الحياه
الحديثه ويوفق بين حاجاتها وشريعه
الاسلاميه وهو ما تبرهن عليه الهيئات
العلميه والمجامع الفقهيه التي تمارس
الاجتهاد الجماعي قبل سته اشهر وبعد ان
مهد لحلمه بالمذهب المغامسي الجديد
قدس سره طلب الرجل اعفائه من الافصاح عن
نواياه
نحن ناقصينك يا مغامسي والامه تتعرض لما
تتعرض له في الداخل والخارج استحي وتواضع
ينصح العلماء هل تعتقد اصلا ان اهل نطلع
بمذهب جديد
فرمان سلطاني من الصدر الاعظم الى عموم
رعيان في قرطاجا وتوابعها
يطمئنكم عطوفته الى انه لن يترككم للخونه
وهو يتحمل المسؤوليه الان والى الابد
لتصبح تونس القيس كم سوريا الاسد ويا خبر
اليوم بفلوس بكره يبقى ببلاش ما تستعجلوش
كان صبرت راكحه الزيت قضيه الترشح
واعاده ترشح سابقا الاواني انا لا اشر في
بنفسي في
منافسه ايا كان
اشعر انني اتحمل المسؤوليه
ولن اتخلى عن
المسؤوليه ولست مستعدا لان اسلم وطني لمن
لا وطنيه لهم تفيد الدراسات العلميه ان
يوما واحدا بلا نوم يعرض صاحبه للهلوسه
فماذا بعد الهلوسه اذا امتنع احدهم عن
النوم ستا وثلاثين ساعه يحدث خلل كبير في
الاداء المعرفي الرئيس قيس سعيد يعمل لست
وثلاثين ساعه متواصله يعرض نفسه للهلوسه
ولخلل المعرفه من اجلكم افلا تشكرون العمل
متواصل في تقريبا على 10 12 ساعه او 36
ساعه في بعض الاحيان
سناء او طفله منطقه طفله في المغرب
اغتصبها ثلاثه فروخ وحوش رفعوا عليها
السكاكين وهي في سن الحاديه عشر حملت
وولدت طفلا يبلغ اليوم عاما وثلاثه اشهر
الجرح لا يندمل لكن قد يخففه حكم قضاء
عادل لكن صفعه الكبرى تلقتها سناء
وعائلتها والمجتمع المغربي من قاض اخذته
الرافه بالمغتصبين فحكم عليهم بالسجن
عامين فقط نظرا لظروفهم الاجتماعيه الصعبه
قال
[موسيقى]
هنا في الرباط تظاهرت عشرات النشطات امام
مقر محكمه الاستئناف احتجاجا على حكم
بالسجن عامين في حقه ثلاثه متهمين باغتصاب
طفله لا يتجاوز عمرها احد عشر عاما اثر
هذا الحكم صدمه في المغرب لان العقوبه
تتراوح بحسب القانون المغربي بين عشره
اعوام وعشرين عاما سجنا وتزايدت ردود
الفعل المستغربه لهذا الحكم بعد نشر اجزاء
منه ويوضح ان الحكم استند الى مراعاه
الظروف الاجتماعيه للمتهمين وزير العدل
المغربي عبد اللطيف وهبي مصدوم من حكم
القاضي لكنه اعرب عن ارتياحه الاستئناف
النيابه العامه الحكم ووعد بالخير عائله
الضحيه التي ترفض والابنه مصاهره احد
المغتصبين الحمد لله الناس ديال وزاره
العدل المهم اعطونا وعود قال لك يكون
الخير ان شاء الله كل شيء تاخذ حقك
صدمه صدمت
ما كاينش الحق باين وما عطاهش بعض الدول
العربيه استمدت بعض قوانينها من التشريعات
الاوروبيه رغم فشلها في ارض المنشا مثلا
عام 2017
اوقفت محكمه فرنسيه عقوبه سجن لمدرس مارس
العلاقه الزوجيه مع تلميذاته القاصر
وبراته من تهمه افسادها وفي عام 2018 واجه
القضاء الفرنسي صعوبه في التعامل مع رجل
اصطحب طفله في سن الحاديه عشر الى بيته
دون اذن اهلها وعاشرها معاشره زوجيه لان
النيابه العامه قالت انها كانت علاقه
بالتراضي لكن بالطبع تجرم قيم الجمهوريه
الفرنسيه الزواج دون سن الثامنه عشر لانها
تكون طفله لكن هذه الطفله باستطاعتها قبل
ذلك بسنوات ان تزني قانونيا برضاها كيفما
ومتى تشاء ومع من تشاء وهكذا تكون قد نضجت
وشبعت نضجا فتصل الى زوجها المصون بخبره
خمس سنوات على الاقل
[موسيقى]
اخيرا لقطه القطه التي قفزت الى كتف
الامام الجزائري وليد مهساس الاسبوع
الماضي استمرت اصداؤها هذا الاسبوع حيث
طافت الارض وتناقلتها وسائر الاعلام
العالميه بكل اللغات وتتجه نحو رقم
الملياري مشاهده اللقطه جميله وبسيطه جدا
وليس فيها اي عجيبه لكن الشيخ تعامل مع
القطه برفق وطيب خلق فخطف القلوب مع انها
لم تكلف قرصا واحدا لكنها تفوقت على
مليارات الدولارات التي انفقت على ما يسمى
جهلا المسلسلات الرمضانيه لتتجاوب مع
ترتيله قطه اعتلت كتفه ليربط عليها دون
انقطاع عن القراءه وتستمر هي في مداعبته
وكانها ترسل رساله الى العالم اجمع عن
سماحه الاسلام
قل فالى الحجه البالغه فلو فيديو ثواني
بسيطه استطاع ان ينتشر كالنار في الهشيم
محققا ارقى من عجزت اغلب المسلسلات
الرمضانيه الوصول اليها
المتربصون اكل القط لسانهم وغابوا عن
المشهد ما خلى تغريد طائشه عثر عليها في
حساب المخرج المصري خالد منتصر الذي سبق
ان نشرت اسرته بيانا تبرات فيه من افكاره
التي يشكك فيها بثوابت الدين الاسلامي
حاول ان يتهضمن فقال هناك قفزتان غيرتا
تاريخ البشريه قفزه ارمسترونج على سطح
القمر وقفزه القطه على كتف الشيخ مهساس
فيقول له بهيج في اسماء العرب خالد واحد
غير تاريخ المنطقه هو خالد بن الوليد رضي
الله عنه لم يهزم في معركه قط وهناك خالد
اخر خسر ولم يربح حتى عائلته والمفارقه ان
هذا المهزوم اسمه منتصر
ختاما ان طريق الاستقلال يجب ان تمهده
الدماء هذا الكلام لم يقله قائد حروب بل
رجل السلام غاندي وهو لم يقله حبا بظرف
الدماء بل كرها باراقتها على يد الاعداء
فالوطن الذي ليس فيه رجال يدافعون عنه
بدمائهم بالسلم وبالحرب ستسير دماء ابنائه
بحراب الغزاه والبحتلين هكذا يقول التاريخ
الوثيق والتاريخ لا يكذب فالاحتلال ترفعه
الهيبه والاستقلال لا يتسول عند ابواب
الدول القويه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
الامم الغ
ريب
لمعرف
ه
صل على الموت يبدو
[موسيقى]